and he flashed the camera with a flare
and i thought oh that's
perfect oh my god it will never happen
again oh
how tragic that i hope they use that
take so we rolled again
how do you know an actor is the real
deal well i would say there are
different flavors of real deal you know
there are different
there are people who bring the
performance in different ways that are
moving
and convincing but
you know it's it's really those moments
when i'm behind a camera
and and i disengage as a technician and
become an audience member you know and
and i
feel a tear in my eye or i have to take
my hand off the camera because i'm
laughing so hard that it's gonna shake
the camera or or
there's a scene in california christmas
that where um
cali and her mom are in
uh the truck talking about her mom's
uh cancer and and every time we did that
scene i just wanted to
walk from behind the camera and just go
give him a hug you know i just had this
strong like oh my god i'm so sorry
and
those are the moments for me
you know when
you know or or also i've worked on
movies where somebody played a bad
person
and and you know i remember thinking on
set that you know that guy's kind of an
and then and then later on like
we become best friends you know so it's
it's it's very weird you know um i
worked with rutgerhauer once and uh
my god that guy was just amazing and
this is another one of those things that
we could do a whole one of these just
with my rutger hour stories but i'll
tell you one of my favorite ones is um
we were shooting in brazil and we were
shooting out in the uh
the rain forest near ubertuba
and we were in a hut and rutger was
standing by a window threatening
somebody and i had a low camera angle
looking up at him
and i remember i was watching through
the camera and he's like you know yada
yada yada yada and this chrome was kind
of his gun was chrome and you know yada
yada yada and austin he did said
something and this precise moment he did
a gesture with the gun and he flashed
the camera with a flare and i thought oh
that's
perfect oh my god it will never happen
again oh
how tragic that's i hope they use that
take so we rolled again and
by god he flashed the camera again and
i'm like well now that can't be a
coincidence
so i go up and i ask rutger now you know
rutgers a legend i mean he did blade
runner and the hitcher and
legend and heaven knows what else and so
i'm
there's not a lot of actors i work with
where i'm a fan and i just kind of have
to not let that
you know surface up but he you know i
just thought the world to him and the
other thing is when you get to know him
because you know so many his characters
are just big meanies but he was a teddy
bear he was a
gentle soul and an artist
so i go up
and i say rutgers are you flashing the
lens and he goes oh i'm sorry do you not
like that i don't have to do it and i'm
like no
my god how do you have that level of
control and the geometry to just get
that right
and to know that to punctuate
that that that that scene i was just
like and he was so humble and so
unpretentious
um he he would ask me you know what lens
is it is there a 50 50s and i would tell
him it was a 35 and he'd be like and he
would play everything inside
i never had to say raise the gun you
know you're out you know you're you're
outside your he knew if i told him what
that lens was he knew where he needed to
be
um and um
you know i just such an amazing guy i
have to tell you one more story of his
there was another scene where we had a a
plane crash and it was
in another world it would have been a
second unit scene because it really
didn't have the principal actors in it
and so it was rutgers day off and they
had built this nose cone of a plane a
full-size nose cone and we had a field
and they wanted to just put bodies in it
and people were kind of you know going
around helping the wounded um
and you know so we're out there getting
this set up and the director says
brad you know raise the camera and i'm
like okay so i lean over and the camera
assistant unlocks a leg and i unlock a
leg i'll lock this and we lift it up
and then she locked a leg i locked a leg
and this other hand comes in and locks
the leg and i look over it's freaking
rutger and like
rutgers what are you doing here it's
your day off he says i don't want to sit
around the hotel this is where all the
fun is he i'm sure he didn't get paid he
came out there and he was he was helping
them place background
this is rutger freaking howard his place
in background and locking tripod legs
you know that he was a solid dude man
and and you know now bless him that he's
passed away i want to tell you that his
email address was fartville aol.com
gotta love this guy right
what qualities are you looking for in an
actor
it seems like a strange question to ask
a dp but um
because i don't really get to ch choose
the actors
but things that i appreciate i mean i
appreciate their ability to hit a mark
if they don't hit a mark oh you know my
poor acs you know especially on the long
lenses and the focus
um but yeah i like them to be able to
hit a mark i like them to have a sense
that you know if we follow their hands
that they don't go quick because if i'm
doing a tilt and they go you know
lift it up quick i'm gonna lose it you
know have a nice you know let me be able
to understand that the camera is
following you
um
you know to be able to find their light
to have a sense that you know this if i
hold my face this way i've got good
light on it but if i look that way i got
shadows in my eyes you know some people
are just you know like a guy like
rutgers just
he's gonna be there you know but maybe
somebody else i may be like you know you
have to keep raising your chin because
when you put your chin down i can't see
your eyes
um
uh
you know the ability to have again just
have a sense of where the camera is
you know
especially with things like stunts but
you know stunt coordinators can help
with that
um
but you know really
uh those are the things that i and of
course i want them to be good performers
because if if their performance is crap
it doesn't matter how good it looks
but you know
i work with good actors these days i
don't it's been a long time since i
worked with anybody that i thought was
wanting as a performer
you know sometimes you have the
extraordinary ones rutger was
extraordinary i worked with uh elliot
gould and lainey kazan they were just
stunning fabulous
um
you know josh and lauren were magical
you know
and again i'm i know i'm leaving out
people who i shouldn't when i cook
county you know xander berkeley anson
mount ryan donahoe polly cole
you know all of those leads were just
just amazing i mean you know people
wouldn't hate that movie not i mean
everybody doesn't but the people who
just vehemently don't like it wouldn't
feel that way if those karen's
characters weren't real to them
you know and for the people who do like
the movie it's tragic for the same
reason because those characters are real
um you know whereas california christmas
was just that perfect
magical escape in the time of
covid for everybody who just wanted that
magic and and you know they brought it
and um
you know amanda detmer the one who
played the mom you know the little girl
hannah
you know i mean they were just all of
them
david del rio who was manny ali afshar
um
you know the fellow who played connor i
mean
that's like you know again it's just it
was just like every one of those person
was a hit and one of the things that's a
little off topic but one of the things i
loved about it which i credit equally
to the actors and to sean the director
and to lauren the screenwriter
is that all of those characters are
sympathetic i mean even the ones in with
the conflicts the ones that in a
stereotype
presentation you would you know they
would be the villain it's like they were
all complex and if you really thought
about it sympathetic so um you know i i
just i i love all of that kind of thing
from a performance point of view but but
really again you know if you ask me as a
dp it's you know hit your marks find
your light
and and don't move so fast that the
camera can't follow you
what do you do when time is running out
and the actor does not have the lines
memorized
that's the director's problem
what can i
there's not diddly squat i can do um you
know maybe they do um
you know maybe they do cue cards
um typically unless it's specified we
don't have a teleprompter and even with
a teleprompter they'd be looking into
the lens you could put you actually you
could take a teleprompter and put it off
outside the lens um
you know i don't know if i was the
director what would i do i mean i guess
i would cover it in a way that i could
try and be on angles where i could loop
it later you know i would try
you know and i i would simplify the
dialogue i would like cut stuff out like
how you know can you at least memorize
this
um
and if it was a chronic problem i guess
you'd have to think about recasting
so
yeah that's my answer
you